as an entrepreneur I'm such an advocate
for everyone to think like an
entrepreneur whether you want to start
your own business or not it's incredibly
helpful no matter what and so thinking
like an entrepreneur inside of
organizations or if you are starting
your own business I always say I love to
tell the people around me to do this
close your eyes and take a minute and
think about how you would be doing your
job if nobody showed you how to do it
what surfaces because if you think about
it we're all on autopilot we're doing
things the way either someone else
showed us how to do it or we saw and
learned from watching and real change
only happens when you do it different
than everybody else so all the time I
put myself through mental exercises
where I'm like wait a minute I know
everybody's been doing it this way for a
really long time but is that the best
way and I just see what comes up I also
come across ideas and inventions by
going throughout my day looking at
objects and saying now how could that be
better and why did the person who first
created the gum or that which gum to me
is so fascinating as someone who started
a brand with $5,000 had to get an idea
out there that didn't already exist the
footless pantyhose I love to think about
people who first introduced things to
society and I think about the guy who
did go I'm like you want to talk about
like can you imagine I thought I had it
tough this guy's like walking around
going you just chew it you just put this
wad in your mouth and like people are
probably and then what don't swallow it
you just chew it like that's a pretty
hard sell you know at first and I think
the gum had no flavor in it when it
first came out so that's even crazier to
me but everything from the pencil to the
fork to the chair we sit in to the car
that we drive somebody originally had
the thought and brought it forward to
society so get off autopilot look at
everything every object in your life the
way that you do things you know when you
get up and brush your teeth is there a
better way to brush your teeth is it the
right way to be doing it and see what
comes
so I started Spanx with $5,000 in stay
from selling fax machines toward a door
in Clearwater Florida
for seven years and I started it out of
the back of my apartment I had never
taken a business class I've never worked
in fashion or retail but I was
determined to make this one particular
undergarment for myself and women that
filled a much needed void and fashion
and it was the most challenging the
first two years to get it made because
no one took me seriously I heard the
word know for two solid years I actually
was calling all the hosiery
manufacturing plants and I ended up
taking a week off of work and drove
around North Carolina in person begging
these people to help make my prototype
and my idea and so there were many many
times in those first two years when I
wrote my own patent I went to Barnes &
Noble and bought a book on patents and
trademarks you know I created the
packaging on my friend's computer after
work you know I thought of the name
Spanx sitting in traffic in Atlanta and
went home and trademarked it with my
credit card for $150 but all of this
time I was doing it I wasn't sharing it
with anybody none of my friends or
family knew what my idea was and that
was really important to my journey
because I didn't want to share the idea
just for validation because I wanted to
make sure that I spent any time I had
pursuing it instead of defending it and
explaining it and I think so often so
many times people have an amazing idea I
mean you have a million dollar a billion
dollar idea
in your life and the first thing you
want to do is turn to your right or left
at work and tell a co-worker tell your
friend tell your husband your wife and
out of love and concern you get a lot of
feedback that stops that idea right in
its moment that it happened and but for
me because I wasn't using a support
system on those times that I had doubt I
ended up really I listened to a lot of
inspirational and motivational lectures
and I would second-guess myself I put
those tapes in I drive around I'd have
to give myself pep talks I mean it was a
real back-and-forth for me to keep
believing in myself when no one else was
[Music]